[Music]
[Applause]
the power
of flowers and friendship
i've done it here ladies and gentlemen
guys the international 2018 was one of
the best ti's
we've ever seen i mean we saw rivalries
unfold
we witnessed unforgettable plays and of
course we saw the ti cycle broken
by a team with a rookie on their roster
now when it comes to og's miracle run
i think machine may have said it best
cinderella
ain't got nothing on this
and that's what it's for that right
there but of course it wasn't all
tearful moments and drama at ti-8 either
it had its fair share of fails
and funny moments as well and we've got
an entire video dedicated just to that
dks ganking but this right here
right now is about the best of the best
not just the best in game either
but we'll also be highlighting some of
our favorite more serious out of game
moments
as well we love the [ __ ] out of you
so without further ado here is the
absolute best of the international
2018. thompson is actually sticking
around has the sentry advantage here
so it doesn't know what ami is up to
kind of looks like he's baiting at they
yeah you did do that he was painting it
he was beating it meteor hammer finish
for sammich starting to put pressure on
mid tower but
he's revealed himself yep they're
looking to chase him down boulder smash
will connect from mss
the first thing you are springing with
sandwich all goes to the duke
for the sprout sam no he's out of it
and the turnaround armour's there with
the right clicks he's picked up a double
kill
mss easy trouble as well he's stuck in
the pit armour with the live strike gets
the triple
sam h oh my lord and in fact they
actually switched ramses ramsey's needs
some time to bomb
on him yeah they tv over solo he's got
the control
zai's got a lot more life holds the
tombstone and streep aside
wait what he got saved by ppd
to play in this bottom together
gonna run into a lot of heroes you don't
want to commit so many onto the venom
but if you can't get any abilities off
it might be enough to the winter's curse
though to turn it back around great play
they're all caught in it you don't like
the rain on the floor there's no coming
from the middle they get the sun off but
it's not going to last
hey turn on direzo get the bash find the
kill mss also
in trouble it's all a btj store fall
this is what happens with the pickup is
not on the lena sev
the perfect fate in lane his team
encroaching upon that area smoked up
ready to battle
and they catch pj storm completely off
guard
there is no way the team secret can
contest this they don't have anything
left in the tank
they can just push out that's all right
hang on mid one hang on you did this
before
he's thinking about doing it again side
of fist but the series chase laughs
right trying to fight basically once
dropping quickly he needs more time
another side of fifth but the jumper
so i'm just seeing if we can find the
rupture at several he goes to farm
that's going to give time for summoners
to close the gap get the rub trough he's
still pretty beefy but is he beefy
enough i don't think so
the shards are out trapping him in the
spin though the taunt the sunshine
he gets the dunk off the snowball safe
wasn't in time and jared he's hit with
the ten the og
they're turning this one around they
look to run down their f5 with the
snowball the shots already used there's
no way to escape or maybe the jukes
isn't enough he gets fog he can't get
the dunk off therefore i will survive
straight in they've got the slow look at
the stun straight up top of it he's
gonna get forced the side step
can he keep this man alive though he
doesn't have the black hole back up you
have a banana with a big gun sending him
back
tornado thompson he's over the back of
the beach
coming down thompson with the save
for them
moonlight shadow out from optic the
observables from vp don't show anything
in the akka slam
oh my god that is just absolutely
perfect then you can let it go too
you will get him with the omni slash but
the follow-up stun from pasha coming out
of the nova
locks down pie cat and four heroes from
optic gone
sunstroke might come up he's watching
and just waiting for let's do some
casting animation bottom lane they're
going to be able to get the disabled on
weaver how is puffy just slipping and
sliding through the map behind these
heroes
and catching them with the shadow
[Music]
control the fissure is out you got a
level two spin and this should be enough
damage to kill off mind control
he can't take to the sky it's got three
stick charges but style just needs uh
two more swings uh with the crit
oh no no no no no no no no no no no
silent not like this oh of this he's
still regenerating
the attack with the sticky napalm
silence gonna go down to mind control
for the fight though thompson's gonna be
fine
it's pretty much up to full hp down
bottom at the same time the eggs
actually come out from fy
as they're beating into it can they kill
him oftentimes they can't fight gets the
supernova successfully off he's playing
around with the three of them here jared
strikes for the dpl
oh but he takes down a base everyone
gets the killer
he gets the kill off said fy
lots of pings walking back towards high
ground they run into everybody they do
have an egg no the chase forwards fear
breaker gonna go down
os4 he's thinking about it oh he wants
it jump forward black hole on the floor
they caught a ball
of the supernova follow-up everybody's
gone triple kill
for sumail easy peasy as they all
go down gg man what a
freaking exclamation mark that's how you
end
a game of dota 2 right there army was
also very low army does of course still
have the aegis he was trying to die
right there
he ran into the thunderstorm but didn't
get it
there we go they're going to need a
little bit more of that magic oh gee
that's easy won't look for in the way of
a turn not enough to bring him down as
passion can
smell himself alive and indeed solo and
roger converging from both sides of the
map it to come into the jungle of evil
geniuses find somehow somehow have the
concoction turn
gets
oh it's gorgeous it's absolutely
beautiful here solo
and roger i'll tell you what they're
going to die together
oh at least solo what does roger
[Music]
there's to be a fight tossing back into
fy's and chan totem did you want to oh
the swap away
it dodges the echo slam now the hands
going to come through global though
we'll make sure that he does not come
home and
zombies in a lot of trouble a spectre
has already joined the fight
they will grab to dj magical swap
saving both of himself and getting the
two kills for his team
[Music]
it's also one of these matches so
close the angles where are they i mean
he's still in the area
he's dead with them and now no one
pretty far
he's gonna find the kill they take him
down
oh yeah there it is no oh i like that no
one with the respect tip
that's very well done yeah carmel
misses the air of the sun so we're going
to give some vision so now we can time
it he has a very good idea of when roger
is going to go downside
poised to strike here comes the roll
with a stun to follow up he gets to
claims it perfectly gets the last hit as
well
zai doda dies immediately brave kingdom
the one who dies off the tnc side
side does have reincarnation immediately
arrow hits the dk as he goes blinking
and they kill the husker
grace king's got no way to survive his
second life he's going to go down as
well 33
somehow doesn't die zai with a magical
little plate
man those team fights were so good
watching them again makes you want to
stand up and scream la code matata
but that's not all we got for you oh no
we thought the team fights at this ti
specifically were so good
they deserved their own section in this
video
he's supposed to be there uh and
hopefully a lot earlier in the game is
mind control
wants to try and crack this one open try
and get up yeah we're up on the high
ground he takes a boat there's the full
combo kit they kill him off in time
though
they're taking down mind control he is
eventually gonna fall mid one barely
living the sendback
it keeps him alive he can jump back into
this fight after what he wants to as
they take down a second winner wife and
gone as well yap start doing so much in
this fight with tumbleman
possibly going to be able to take down
fodder he's silenced for the moment
they're trying to take him down but the
stop is going to be there again
they're taking them all down gh in
trouble and spin one smells blood
they're gonna find each other up on top
lane live break forward
and support it was all about how many
times was top to look like a good kill
the curse
it's actually going to kill off the
plugger or will it challenge
two huge kills and it's about to be
three the reincarnation freaks no tell
back
to a practical death but said he
actually gets to kill the witch doctor
the stones removed
no doubt will still burn nothing was
going to stop that
revealing himself they are still smoked
up on the high ground the remnant is
down as well vp
they're walking right into all the
vision in the world and may be going
right for the initiation as well
to can't make it happen and now the lgd
potentially has an opening here
no one there's gonna be the avatar play
they drop down the boat as well it's
still looking okay for vp
they're trying to bring down one can
they kill them off in time fy is gonna
die
they're buying back on two immediately
back into this fight but they have the
axe onto ame
the tombstone is up on the high ground
and maybe trying to create some chaos
he's doing a good bit of work but down
to very low hp
they're telling him apart the vp is
starting to die they pull up yet another
challenge
making it work can they go up silence
for the visit ramsey is gonna die
we're dead forever maybe found
his moment he baited out that black hole
flawlessly
og they need something here the emp
burned us into anything in fact now they
go back in lgd
thomas on a quick job he's already just
gonna control up thompson
and let the rest of the team do the work
this could be the game the controllers
everywhere
fly back up from thompson he's looking
at summers but then you're out going
from fy hold hold and
kell thompson he's up the racks he's up
the rim
oh the timing nice seth rp
pull them back away from the cataclysm
but into your home
unwelcome visitors therefore still
trying to chase down ramses ramses has
the bkb
pots it turns towards s4 out easy comes
out of the shadow blade a few right
clicks can it bring ramsey down the
error the arrow it connects pascha
looking for the control of the staff
coming out from roger the side
the spinner as well
at a time where it looked like vp were
maybe just about able to set up a
turnaround somehow comes balling in
and secures the three kills they needed
to keep bg afloat in this steam fight
any lips oh no another turnaround
they're in
the fisher the zip they're on top of
both of them chalice
he's popped zomness he's now surrounded
fbi does come in just get the doom down
onto xxs as xxs will surely fall army
turning up and look at the speed of this
man
gets tossed forward as well army zipping
around here oh my god seeker picks up
the double gets the triple getting q as
well
that'll be an ultra killer buyback is
there from boboka
he's steeping across the train he knows
somnis is low he wants to try and fight
it army with the bkb down though
the bluff right out he looks towards
aggressive getting the bash is killing
off the specters
get the chain anna in the midst of it
trying to lock down onto fy
the rest of his team about to come over
to get the tornado out onto its overstep
looking for the cool controller
has he got it i've been getting stunned
by the concept but he's able to wait for
him up the higher
top turn
will be able to find the io but they're
fully low ogd that's soldered
for two minutes they get thompson's
total differentiability sodiana
anna can you do it here is
he gets the goal of his
lifetime guys as much as we love the
underdog moments
the plays the team fights from this ti
they wouldn't mean
quite as much without some of the more
serious out of game moments
that came with them and that's true for
the winners
and the losers so here are some of our
favorite more serious out of game
moments
from ti8 so we're gonna talk about the
thing that everybody is talking about
which is s4 and fly leaving and you all
had to reset
pretty quickly no-till for you how
what was that like going through that
change i'm actually not that willing to
talk about it
yeah it's uh something for later another
day
can you help people understand why you
don't want to talk about it so that
they'll we can all leave you alone
it's just personal it's nobody's
business right
what unbelievable comebacks we have
between these two teams in two
back-to-back games
og with the fortitude to stick through
it with such importance
oh the look there from nota
i mean you can feel it this game
yesterday no tell
he got a another nickname a new chinese
nickname
it's killer it's like killing machine
killing machine that is so badass
uh yeah there's a sentences about
no-till okay what's the sentence i'm a
killer
i have no emotion this is what the
chinese community are saying about
noticing
i mean to be fair after that performance
and that picture that we'll forever live
on in our minds
shake your hand yeah are we doing it
okay i'm mckayla
i have no emotion you know there's a lot
of teams here that have some something
against us as a team
so it's not too hard to find uh to find
like rivals uh but i hope i'll take you
you feel like there's a lot of teams
against you here i mean it's just like
every time we play against somebody you
know there's always some
some problem you know i know og had a
lot of bitterness towards us
i don't know why i feel like there's
obviously no villain in this story like
two teams came out of
came out better but uh yeah i guess we
just have to take it as it comes
no bad blood from your side no not
really
to get anna back right and you're back
in the finals
i guess that's what it took ran me
through the games
the first race the first race
[Music]
before they're prepared for it they
think they can handle it and uh i would
say that the room mother wasn't like
absolutely the biggest problem in this
game right i mean it's just this
fantastic tool for team liquid they use
it so well
play around it amazingly probably better
than anyone so
it's so hard to compare you gotta love
the respect
to fellow captains former teammates
and of course the young guns they're
surrounded themselves with
very impressive performances one more
hug full of you can feel it in the
stadium here
i feel like we're missing out on
something i think someone's trying to i
think toby's trying to start a wave over
there oh and it's not too successful
wait let's see
[Applause]
oh there we go
oh this stadium is so packed
there you go
they keep their hopes alive being the
first to repeat as ti champions
as you see them
what's your motivation money money yeah
definitely everyone else is going to
tell you they're playing because they're
passionate yeah
[Music]
i mean that's the good thing right like
i'm the best at it but i can also make
money out of it so it's just a bonus
but you have to pick one money or the
ego or the total title
what am i gonna do with the title i'll
take the money
but what are you doing fond it clearly
says
on the schedule you're going to be
casting this game with me this was going
to be our ear fogged
and you got to you got to stand me up
like this i'm here on my own
casting open ai this is not going to be
any fun at all is it
[Applause]
what's up hello how's it going i i feel
like i'm in trouble
you could you've turned up bruno
ladies and gentlemen both teams are
ready for the match and to bring you the
grand finals it's odie pixel fog
and ben merlini whoa
yes reza was a poor guy
from a small town called nicoball and
one internet cafe was the
worst internet in europe so when he
finished his medal skill he decided i
need to start my career i need to start
playing seriously in this game
yeah so he moved to kiev to the capital
of ukraine a big city
and he was going every day to internet
cafe he was sitting
next to one of his friends
he was watching his friends to play some
dota he was trying
to learn something from that guy and
when that guy was asking
come on roman bring me some water i want
to drink some water bring me some
sandwich i want to eat some sandwich
brazil was doing that
and that guy was always want to fly
legion
[Music]
i do want to talk about that is it true
that reza used to get you water
yeah yeah for two years for two years
yeah in internet coffee
and he drink my water were you surprised
he agreed to do that
yeah yeah now it is my job
thank you do you feel a little bit
responsible for some of his success
a bit yeah always want to fly with the
first friend of president dota
he brought brazil to professional dota
and today brazil
defeated always want to fly an amazing
guy do you remember
after the game yeah yeah i was like
trying to hold my tears looking
and of course the love from the
ukrainian brethren you gotta love it
we love the [ __ ] out of you
[Applause]
like it doesn't matter if it's a fan
somewhere or a distant relative
or anybody that's very close to you it's
just
having it said out loud i mean it makes
all the difference in the world
in a way it's the only way that we can
help carry this burden for you
as much as we can it's i mean it has
made a difference
it's crazy how different it
is thank you for coming out to the
netherlands as well
oh great i love your family yeah i'm
sure they love you but you did make
every single one of them cry sorry gods
i didn't think there was anyone more
teary than me on this i know but i think
you might be beating me buddy
you're right
[Music]
okay i think we'll move on but thank you
jima thank you all right i'm gonna steal
the cheese screw all of you
hey hey i am dutch if anything oh yeah
that's right the duchies like their
cheese
bon appetit my queen let me hear you
team shiva take the all-star game well
guys that's all we got for you on this
episode of best of now let me tell you
this video could have been about twice
as long
i mean what a ti we saw the cycle broken
and the aegis of champions lifted by a
rookie no less
alongside of course our little flower no
tail now if you want more help fighting
the post ti blues
i suggest you go ahead and echo slam
that subscribe button so you know
exactly when we publish more ti
and dota 2 content thanks for watching
if you want more great content just like
this
be sure to hit the subscribe button